Speaker 1: This is I have to tell you, this
is just a hilarious story. Rudy Giuliani or
Giuliani, depending on your preference, he
apparently has been banned from Fox News
for a while now. There's a Rolling Stone article.
Rudy Giuliani whines about Fox News Band to Steve
Bannon Rudy is apparently very hurt over
getting booted from a network who's facing
a one point six billion dollar lawsuit because
of the former mayor's remarks. It appears that
this is sort of like an informal ban of Rudy from
Fox News, because the stuff that he spent months
saying on Fox News and other networks since the
election of 20/20 have gotten Fox News and other
media outlets into a lot of trouble. During
the taping of the War Room podcast on Friday,
Bannon asked Giuliani how the network
could put him on double secret probation,
particularly over 9/11. There's no reason to
include his son, Andrew, Rudy Giuliani said.
Let's take a look at the video clip. This,
by the way, this video is crazy because
Rudy talks about being banned from Fox News.
But as like a secondary layer of insanity,
Steve Bannon says that the electors from, I
guess, Arizona are going to be decertified.
The electors are not going to be decertified. I
don't even know what that means. But then Rudy
complains about being banned on Fox News, like
what Bannon says is crazy for its own segment,
quite frankly. Let's take a look at Rudy
Speaker 3: Giuliani and look at it now. The
mock and ridicule, OK, they could be mocking or
ridiculing when the criminal referrals come out
and also wait for it. Decertification these
elections and these electors are going to be
decertified. OK, as sure as the turning of
the earth, they're going to be decertified.
And I understand up on Capitol Hill, the Democrats
don't like that. I'm sorry. That's just a fact.
And every day we're Grigny and we're not backing
off Rudy. How can Fox News put you on double
secret probation in particular over 9/11 and
also include your son, who I think is running
for the governorship in New York? That isn't worth
Speaker 4: I mean, there's no there'd be no reason
to include Andrew, but I mean, gee, they do a
pretty good separation between Hunter Biden and
Joe Biden. Gosh, you know, that's outrageous.
But the fact is that every single thing that
Speaker 2: I said about Arizona is
Speaker 1: right here. So it's really
not going super well for Rudy Giuliani. This
has become a pretty sad chapter. But Giuliani
apparently. He was scheduled to appear on
Fox and Friends on 9/11, like this past 9/11,
and Pete Hegseth, who's one of the hosts of Fox
and Friends, called Giuliani the night before
to inform him he'd been cut. Fox denies this and
says Rudy wasn't scheduled to be on the show, Fox
did not deny that Giuliani had been banned. So my
reading of this is as far as Fox and Friends knew,
Rudy was scheduled to be on the show. Hegseth
Seth called Rudy and said, you're not going to
be on anymore. And when Fox News says Rudy wasn't
scheduled to be on, all that might mean as Rudy is
not allowed on at all. So he couldn't possibly
have been scheduled because he's not allowed on
the show. But at the show level, Fox and Friends
might have been planning or hoping to have Rudy on
very sad chapter in Rudy's political career of
a very long chapter. This entire Trump chapter
is getting pretty long. Would make
for a pretty interesting documentary,
a sort of tragic comedy, the farting at
the fraught events, the leaking hair dye
while lying about the election, like every
policy or more substantive related failure,
is alongside some other type of failure, like the
farting or the leaking hair dye or whatever the
case may be. They do not want Rudy exposing
them to more legal liability on Fox News.
I think it's that simple as far as why he
hasn't been there and what Rudy Giuliani's
next chapter is, is anyone's guess. But Rudy
apparently banned from Fox News. And the sort of
bigger picture story that we've been seeing is
there is now this growing piece of the right wing
that is too crazy for Fox News and this applies
both to guests and to viewers. So Fox has said
no Rudy Giuliani for now. Reportedly, there's also
a large contingent of trumpets who say Fox is now
on the left. No more Fox with its Newsmax. It's on
its Steve Bannon's war room or whatever. Whatever
the case may be, this is a further radicalization
of the right, which we talked about earlier,
and I won't spend more time on now, but a
very important part of what's going on here.